welcome to academy dialogues my name is
sean finney
i am honored to guide this conversation
today with
three individuals that i believe are
shaping our culture
through film and that is writer director
gina prince bye the wood
oscar winner tj martin and the
incomparable incredible
deroy lindo welcome everybody thank you
thank you first i mean when we say it's
good to see you now
it just takes on a whole new level based
on where we are
in the world so first i want to just
check in how are you doing
gina we can start with you how are you
doing how are you managing in this time
it's so funny because that's my go-to's
like you say you know how are you
and uh it's such a loaded question um
yeah it's uh it's it's a
very scary time right now um a couple
weeks ago i was saying
that it felt like a hopeful time given
that
felt the true change was finally coming
um that in this moment instead of people
being defensive people were finally
understanding
uh what we've been fighting for for for
all these years and hearing us
um but right now i have kind of gone
back to
it feeling like a scary time and i think
what's uh
indicative is uh my son who's 19
got pulled over by police for the first
time
and uh
when uh yeah when was your son
two days ago wow and um
the fact that my husband and i didn't
even have the luxury
of being able to be angry at him for
getting a speeding ticket
our first question was you know are you
okay
and then he survived it and that the
fact that that's where our mind goes
uh is is pretty insane
wow and delray i know you also have a
son
so i'm sure when 19 i have a 19 year old
yeah
so when you hear that as a creative but
also as a human and as a parent
how does that register with you
uh what gina just said yeah what gina
just said um
first of all the fact that gina
acknowledged that it is a loaded
question
and it is and it's it's loaded from my
standpoint
because it is chock full of
so many potential responses that one
could have
to the question how are you doing one
can respond in any number of different
directions
[Music]
when i hear gina saying that her 19 year
old was pulled over
and my 19 year old
has been pulled over and
was also in a he wrecked his car a few
months ago then car wreck um
well no he wrecked his car he was he's
fine
um but i really relate
to the various responses that one
has uh
are you okay uh it happened at
three in the morning uh my lady ended up
going to where he was
thank god somebody had stopped a brother
had stopped
and stayed with him until my lady
and a law enforcement officer got there
it happened that the law enforcement
officer was
reasonable a reasonable human being
[Music]
so all of that was positive
but
you know what i i think the
most
honest or authentic thing that i can say
in terms of responding to that question
is that there is a
i don't want to say a deadening of of um
responses of emotional responses but
there's a blunting
of responses just because
there are so many responses that one has
um to your question how am i doing
in context of everything that's going on
i'm doing okay and probably no not
probably
better than okay because you know i am
i'm working right now
millions of people are not as we know
i am able to therefore because i'm
working support
my family that is an extraordinary
almost a luxury
in these times so i am constantly
attempting to take a half a step back
from my present
and try at lea try at least to
figure out perspective
so there are these multi steps that one
takes and um so
no that's the most honest and thank you
for the honesty and i feel like this
academy dialogue this whole thing was
created to give our members a platform
to speak
their truth and to talk about all of the
issues and things that are happening in
the community
as it relates to art and as it just
relates to the human experience
uh tj howard you might say one more
thing before before you go to tj and and
not to dwell on this and perhaps we can
discuss it later in the conversation
if if it come if it comes back around
but when gina said
a few weeks ago she was feeling hope she
was feeling hopeful
my response was why
and
i respond that way not as a challenge
to gina or anybody else but i'm curious
about i find myself being curious about
what are the components
what were the components of your
hopefulness
uh weeks or months ago whenever it was
that you were feeling hopeful
and what are the components that have
caused
um your current response because that's
a whole other
that's a whole other series of
conversations but again
um uh that's that's i just wanted to
mention that we can we can definitely uh
go to that right after this uh right
after tv
yeah please yeah yeah dj how are you
uh as everyone pointed out it's a it's
it's a weighted question right i
if i'm gonna be completely honest um
i'm processing right and active
processing
i think there's a wide range of emotions
that come with it um
it's i think for me in terms of like i
have a tremendous amount of anxiety
right now part of that probably is in a
really practical manner i'm in between
projects so
i tend to process through the work
and um it brings my mind at ease to be
able to actually take that energy and
and package it and put it in a direction
um
and without that uh
[Music]
the the ups and downs are very
visceral and palpable for me and it's
not
and i don't think it's because of
necessarily
that
it's not because things have
fundamentally changed by any means
it's that the the the flaws of this
country
there's just the window had the curtains
have been
open and the curtains are open and
people
i have i'm i'm
appalled by the inability to actually
have
a an conversation
about who we are as a community
and that i find really um unnerving and
it's it's hard to
even with this kind of really
diverse coalition of allies
um and what allyship looks like in 2020
um you know the blowback is equally
discouraging and um
and i find that we're all processing
kind of
out loud on our social media feeds we're
all processing internally
and um
and i don't necessarily think we're
having healthy dialogue i think this is
why this is so important because i think
it is one of the few forms that where
you can actually have a healthy dialogue
but i think
yeah i don't there's not one to delroy's
point there's not one dominant
emotion it's kind of uh it's minute to
minute day by day hour by hour at least
for me
you know i had a ton of anxiety this
morning and then by noon
you know i spoke i did a webinar with a
bunch of
young filmmakers at usc specifically
black women um that are doing projects
non-fiction projects
as a result of the current civil unrest
like a lot of the projects are motivated
by that
and that brought me a ton of ease you
know and then now i feel good you know
and then by the night maybe i'll be
tripping again you know so it's like
it's
it's an ongoing dialogue with myself in
the world right so i mean in the most
honest way you said that is is
processing right which means you're
neither here nor there and you're in
transition
going back to what delroy mentioned
earlier and we talk a lot about change
right the need for change
change change but in order for things to
change something has to have changed
right and so to your point delroy when
you were asking
gina and you were saying you were
feeling hopeful before what gave you
that that hope gina what what
brought you to that point to delroy's
question earlier
i felt you know that it was a couple
things i mean it was certainly as tj
just mentioned the allyship
felt different this time it didn't feel
uh
it didn't feel simplistic it felt um
that there were true allies coming out
and putting themselves
uh in harm's way in the way that we've
had to by ourselves
um within the uh you know kamala
being chosen was a was a big deal um
watching the democratic convention and
made me feel hope about what could be
um and then within our industry to
finally have conversations with
people that i've worked with and had
those hard conversations
you know one in particular
why do i need to walk into your offices
and not pass
one black person from you know the
reception desk all the way to your
corner office
and for the first time people not being
defensive
but actually accepting that they have
messed up in a big way
and being um
having a certainty about changing it and
knowing
why it needed to be changed um
so and then the other thing was there
are so many collectives
of of black artists coming together
from from all all of it from acting
directing producing below the line
we're all coming together in such a big
way for the first time
and seeing and understanding and feeling
our power and that has
felt really good because we've never
done that before
um but i
i think that thing that changed for me
and it's
you know been been a slow grind back
you know this this kid this 17 year old
kid who killed the protesters
uh and the fact that he is being
excused by you know
the white house and and others i i
cannot wrap my head around
how far we have fallen as a country if
when that is happening
and from that point on it does seem as
tj
mentioned that we've got this great
allyship but the
but the blow back is starting to feel
even stronger and i just know the fight
that we are in
in this moment to literally for survival
when you're when you talked about the
the community aspect
i resonated because in our community
like you said before maybe we weren't as
collaborative before or weren't working
together as closely
and for all of you are you noticing that
that change in as we go to the younger
generation are you noticing that they're
wanting to work together more
and what can we learn from that if so
um well i work you know i work in
non-fiction and our
crews are not as big and my
creative partner and i we do a lot of
the heavy lifting like in
from shooting to cutting to everything
um
but you know in the when we're doing
when we're working in the commercial
space we're
10 up obviously bigger cruise but
you know i think i think there's still
kind of a um i still think there's
uh no pun intended but there's an old
guard with
uh within the
within the industry um i think there's a
tremendous amount of nepotism
um and
even even for a younger generation that
has the um
the like a vision for how they want to
participate
in the industry i still think they're
met with
some really rigid um
blockades um and i think i think like a
lot of people right they
you it's that becomes an opportunity to
mold how you want to handle that um
and how you want to integrate yourself
and then once you integrate yourself how
do you what do you do once you integrate
yourself within
kind of the confines of the industry
even though it's kind of it's a
day-to-day
you know organized chaos but but i think
i think the what i the thing that i am
encouraged by
is like any institution
the it's unfortunate but it's also just
the way it is
the i find that there are younger voices
advocating for change and forcing the
hand of the
of the institution aka the industry
to examine itself and help facilitate
change
um that just that's always been the case
with any institution it's always an
outside force
but i love the fact that at least
younger voices are not
dropping the ball in that regard and
that i find
um really encouraging and i want to
collaborate with those people
we talk about you know often nina simone
has this quote how can you be an artist
and not reflect the times
right and we talk about that
responsibility and i wanted to ask you
all
and delroy starting with you is it is it
the artist's responsibility alone
or is it a collaboration with the system
with the industry with
with that that it is in your opinion
uh what do i think about that i think
that
obviously it is a very personal
and intimate choice that one makes for
oneself
but my personal excuse me my personal
response to the question is that yes i
do feel a responsibility
um but i want i want to say that and
this goes back to something you said
sean at the beginning of the
conversation
um having to do with i
i think i'm a human being first yes
for any other definitions descriptives
definitions
i'm a human being first and i want to
say
first and foremost um
so i think i'm always responding as a
human being
albeit that at a certain point
i am filtering my responses
through the conduit of my creative self
but going back to the one of the when we
were talking about our kids our 19 year
olds
i'm responding as a parent period
period the end that's it no more
and no less so uh to answer your
question
um personally yes i feel a
responsibility
but i i think i am not defining my
various responses
as an artist i think i'm defining
my responses as a human being on the
planet
does that make sense that makes all of
the sense of the world tj i would say to
you following up with that
how does that impact the way that you
approach film you know we saw
you won the oscar for undefeated which
follows a memphis football team
having a over 100 year losing streak
and you that power of them
seeing themselves as that and then what
happened
when you came into it how did that
affect your approach to coming into
working
with them how did it affect my approach
in terms of
in terms of you're working with you know
the power of imagery right you're
working
with a team who sees themselves as
losers for about a hundred years
and a decision to highlight that and how
that
invertedly changed the power of how they
saw themselves
because they ended up winning after that
well
they did not win this well i'd be giving
away part of the movie but
in the season that we covered they still
were on a losing streak but the
i mean i i so
the challenge with undefeated was that
you know when you do a verite film
you're trying to
express to the audience at least the way
my filmmaking partner and i see it the
emotional
experience that you have right because
you you know we embedded ourselves with
this
high school football team in north
memphis for the
the senior year of the first group
of students that came in and she
reshaped the program
with this gentleman named though
courtney who was the coach so
it's the the way
with which these students see themselves
we can't take credit for that that's
very much of the the
bill and the volunteers that created a
program
that we're committed to the
to the students and to the student
athletes
and we're not doing it for selfish
purposes but rather
you know the the coach had moved to
north memphis he moved his business
there
and as a result he wanted to give back
to the community so he was a permanent
fixture of the community
um but the so the film can't take credit
for that
but our job was to go in and um create
can we capture the essence of what the
relationships were
so a lot of the biggest challenge with
undefeated in particular
was you've got a
north memphis which is
99.9 black and you've got
a white coach volunteer coach coming in
from east memphis
and one of the things that attracted us
to the to the story to begin with was
one of the players was spending hardest
time with the coaches in east memphis
living there throughout the week
and then living with his grandmother in
north memphis during the weekend
and it was an opportunity to use either
this particular student or the team's
story
to kind of explore race in class
and use this experience as a reflection
of how we talk about race and class in
the country
but then the the football narrative
itself became so
so good and so fascinating that that's
still present but
through the conduit of a football story
but the bigger challenge was
you know i'm i naturally go into
something like that going like you know
this particular coach what he's got
ulterior motives
is he kind of like given the hard sell
on on his relationship with the students
and
the challenge was after spending time
with them
was that there is a fundamental
very real um
uh very healthy relationship between the
coach
and the players now our job is to make
sure that we are not
we recognize the blind spots in the
baggage that an audience is going to
come with
that says is this a white night story
which is a 100 a valid question so how
do we take that
and say good analysis but if we take it
a step further
and we create themes that are a little
bit more about like
fatherhood you actually transcend that
and that was
um that became
a challenge creatively but it was
it was something that was very necessary
to get a film for people to to actually
look
beyond um race in class
in the most and acknowledge it at the
same time
you know what i mean um because you're
not not supposed to acknowledge it
but then can you say oh wow this is a
real relationship
and as a result if we can get that
baggage out of the way then you're
actually looking at
a coming-of-age film you know these
young men that are transitioning
from end of high school into the early
stages of manhood
and that's really what what the what the
film was about
in a space created by
volunteers that allowed them to be
vulnerable
and that was huge and and this is
slightly tangential but that is one
thing i find
i'm always attracted to which is so
rarely seen
is finding spaces for men and
particularly
men of color and particularly black men
to show their vulnerabilities
and feel comfortable doing that so our
job at that point
is to continue to to express to the
audience what our feel
what we experienced um
through the emotions of it and through
the storytelling of it um and then
preserve the integrity
of the space and the vulnerability that
they gave us and allowed us to capture
to capture in in the making of that film
um sorry i don't know if that answers
your question
gina we were talking and um that that
idea of the power of imagery right and
this idea of self-identity
and you've been open about your
childhood and growing up in your
community and kind of really being
the only one or not really seeing people
who look like you how did that affect
the way that you approach film
i mean it certainly absolutely defines
it
um understanding knowing very early the
power of
film and imagery um
you know just in in quick context you
know adopted by a salvadorian mother
and an irish father and um
and raised in in really all white area
and so growing up just never seeing
myself reflected and not even in my own
family and
you know that could do a number on your
self-esteem certainly and
thank god for sports which you know
gave me the applause that that was you
know so desperately craving
um but i i remember distinctly um
uh being 17 years old and and uh
going to see the movie i've got a movie
i was going to see but the trailer for
she's got to have it came on
and uh looking up there and nola darling
and
am i like nola you know who she is no
but it was
me seeing someone who looked up that
looked like me
up on that big screen and i was floored
and
i i've never forgotten that feeling and
for me
from that moment and knowing that i
wanted to tell stories and get into film
and television that
i wanted to give an audience especially
a black audience that
feeling that i had and so for me my work
has been
a fight to to center our stories and and
tell stories in every genre but through
our lens and
um yeah and i'm the first audience so
i'm kind of writing what i want to see
and then my hope is then
that i can inspire and create characters
that
we can be aspired to be and from there
the world can see us in all these
different
ways and see the breadth of our humanity
and be inspired by us as well
and and when you we spoke um you were
also i've
heard you say that when you are able to
see yourself then you're able to see
yourself
and what that does and how it can alter
and change someone's entire
life i mean obviously the opportunity
and versatility right so when we're
talking about telling our stories in
black cinema
while also knowing that it is for the
larger audience it can be a black story
and be universal as well um
delroy have you you've been such a
cultural icon in
a lot of spike lee's early films and a
staple
a staple in the community in which you
and what you mean
to to us and i've also seen your
versatility in just there was a time i
think you
weren't in film and you were just
performing in theater
have you always had that been able to do
that intersection did you see
us there in theater to draw you to that
because you represent something so
magical in that space as well
first of all um were i a more
um 21st century individual
i would have gone on the internet
and looked up tj and gina
and i did not therefore
um tj i did not know that you that the
film undefeated which really moved me
and when you first i did not know that
you were involved
with undefeated so i want to say
congratulate
not only congratulations to you as an
audience
but um an interesting thing happened
when you first mentioned that you you
were you are involved in that film
i got goosebumps goosebumps and the
reason that i got goosebumps
was because that the depth
of the extent to which that film moved
me
for a whole variety of reasons so to the
extent that i gave jaina props
i want to give you props right now
that's that's the first and if i
if i were more on the ball i would have
looked it up before we got
this interview and and i would have led
with that right
that's one thing so props man major
props to you
um when gina when you were speaking
about your
upbringing there were a couple of
um aspects that i
related to um
i was not formally adopted but i but i
did spend when i was very very young i
did i was taken
in by a family that were not my
biological
parents and i also was spent a very
significant
time in my formative years going to all
white schools in all white neighborhoods
um and so i really when you
start talking about not not seeing
yourself reflect
reflected back to yourself i get it
six thousand percent but as it relates
to the making of work
as i'm sitting here listening to your
to your your your narrative it occurred
to me
that what happened with me was
is that the
aspects that i felt as a young person
and the pain
deep seated pain that was
visited on me as a result of being a
black kid in an all-white
excuse me neighborhood a black kid in
all white schools and all that comes
with
um i have been
able to use in my work
the the individual the aloneness
the um the individual what's the word
um the the fact of feeling like one is
alone in the world
um i have um been able to use
um really constructively
not without neuroses not without
pain and all the rest of that but then
the final analysis
one of the foundational aspects of of my
career
frankly is the fact that i have been
able to
mine those things
um for a creative good
um so i'm not quite sure what i'm saying
other than
hearing you inspired me hearing you tell
your story
uh gina a inspired me b
caused me to reflect uh on myself
and these are not reflections i haven't
had before
but just seeing them in a slightly
different different light
and being able now all these years
later to
acknowledge embrace how
the pain of my childhood i would say
i've been able to uh
use and utilize as an adult
um uh
like big time frankly big time
is there a specific role delroy that
that you were able to really use that
the most
and continue using it continue using it
uh um the other thing i want to
i need to add
in this moment is um
the fact i mentioned at the beginning of
the conversation that um
i feel extremely fortunate that i am
working
and i do um and this goes um
shown to your question of how are you
feeling um
added to the fact that i am working
i'm working on a project
and the last project that i did with
spike
um
spikes project and the project that i'm
working on
currently are both narratives
in which we as
african descended people are front and
center
so the narrative is being told
very very very much
from our point of view
and that enhances
the extent to which i feel um
i'm sorry i'm going to use this
hackneyed and overused word but
blessed because i am
um and the fact that
these projects are not look we're in the
middle of
we just started working on this film
that i'm doing right now so i don't know
what the finished result will be but
what i
what i can say is that um
working in the process of doing this
current work
and absolutely working in the process
of having made five bloods and the fact
that
we were front and center
um is again
another hackneyed and overused word but
a gift
that particularly
now in in not only in the met the
in the america that we're living in but
the world that we're living in
the fact that i get to be a part of
excuse me these projects
that have nothing to do with filtering
through somebody else's gaze or
filtering
through somebody else's experience what
the story is
that's an extraordinary thing and it
does
make for me as a creative person as a
human being on the planet it makes a
very profound and positive difference
to how i negotiate
my world with all of its
ugliness and and the fact that we as
african descended people are being
battered we are so we are so
so much being battered right now um
but i have as a human being as a human
as a creative person
i have these islands these oases
of affirmation for
who i am as a as an african descendant
person
as a creative person that not only can i
experience but then i can share with the
rest of the world
which is extraordinary and it is said
that in the um
specific is the universal and you use
the term the word universal a little
earlier in the conversation
and i have gotten to i get to be a part
of i
am i've gotten the gift of being a part
of
very specifically examining
something through the lens of who i am
as a black individual
sharing that with the world and
hopefully affirming
the humanity not black humanity the
humanity
that exists in those journeys
and that's extraordinary
beyond extraordinary i don't have the
words
you know it's i mean obviously there'd
be no reason
i would know i had no idea about you
know your upbringing and that's
so fascinating to me because
you know there's always been a reason
that i've gravitated
towards your work and um
in in everything you there is and i know
you just said
humanity not black humanity but for me
in every role that you've played you've
always for me represented
black manhood and that it wasn't
it's not just dignity and strength but
this innate vulnerability that
might be from the way that you grew up
and the things that you talked about but
given that all of those things made made
a black manhood for me as opposed to
you know so many stereotypes that were
given and um so i'm
grateful to you for that and you know i
would say congrats on the five bloods
but it's really
your whole body of work has always been
that for me
um so again it's fascinating to hear
where some of that has come from
thank you we're talking a lot about
owning your stories which is what i
captured from what you were saying del
roy is us
being in the forefront and behind the
scenes narrating and showing and sharing
our stories and how important it is to
have that
authentic through line as well as
documenting our stories uh
tj which you've documented la 92 which
has been
a story and a staple in our community
talk to me about la 92 and what you've
learned about that and where you think
we are
right now and if there is any change at
all
yeah um for those who haven't seen la 92
it's
it's a it's a film about the
[Music]
civil unrest commonly known as kind of
the rodney king rights but
i prefer civil unrest um in 92 after
rodney king was
um beaten by four motorists
and nearly murdered and then uh sorry
beaten by four cops and nearly murdered
and then the cops
[Music]
getting off on the trial and then it
became to this day the most
um violent uh
monetarily speaking the most uh violent
uh uh civil unrest in american history
um the the
the project was made at the 24
in preparation for the 25 year
anniversary of the unrest
and we knew that there was going to be a
number of films coming out
um it was we did not conceive of the
project it was a production company that
came up with the idea sold it to a
network and they wanted us to direct it
and um they sent over sizzle
and in the sizzle they'd mined some
other early archive and
uh and there's a kind of a moment
in the sizzle where there's a gentleman
from south south central uh that was
captured on film
within his own community and he's kind
of
waving a hammer around and he's uh
he's yelling at the top of his lungs and
he's
um he's very very emotional and he's
crying
and he's saying he had just been looted
um and he's basically yelling around
by to to within his community why steal
from me
i come from the ghetto to you call this
activism you know and he's
you see a man falling apart on the
camera
and uh for us that was
that the vulnerability
in that particular moment was the
um impetus of the approach which is can
you tell
these events only using archive
and preserve the integrity of the
emotion that people experienced
in that moment in time so can you create
an experiential film
and not one that's kind of a talking
head documentary i find that
oftentimes um when we're looking at
critical moments in our history
because it's happened and because
there's a there's a person
giving an analysis um
it creates a buffer between the audience
and the experience that
fundamentally changed people's lives so
the film uh there's a long way of just
saying the film
is is a feature doc only constructed out
of
archive and the idea is to bring
to create an immersive experience um
for audiences that may have lived
through it or
um or for younger audiences that for
younger generations that don't know
anything about it
and the we start the film with um
uh with a prologue of of watts
and then at the end of the film we it
gets pretty editorialized where we're
kind of intercutting between 65 watts
the the silhouette unrest in watts and
the civil unrest in 92.
and so the dominant theme of the film um
is that these events are cyclical um
it's baked into
a system that um
a system of violence and a system of
oppression
um that will never go away
until we actually are able to
[Music]
have people in positions that have
fundamentally
hold the reins of the system change the
system itself
so to answer your question is there what
am i seeing any
differently in 2020 is
you know both on my social media feed
and in twitter
and you know when things really popped
off in la
i i was in the middle of cutting uh our
next film but i just couldn't
i couldn't resist i had to go down and
like experience in real time what
a protest looks like during an epidemic
like it's it's like a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity
so in all three instances what i'm
seeing on my phone what i'm experiencing
in person what i'm reading in the news
the one standout thing is the diverse
coalition of of faces and
um what seems to be allyship now
um i think is fundamentally different
than anything we've ever
seen and when i when i say diverse
coalition i don't mean
um black and white i mean latino
asian american native representation
all speaking out against and
for and on behalf of the black community
actually showing like true allyship and
and
empathy because there's it felt like
there's a fundamental understanding that
if
when when when one member of our
community is attacked that we all suffer
as a result and
we can lift um
lift other communities up we are all
going to also benefit from it it's it's
really
simple it's really however
having said that that is a fundamental
difference
but then my my the the part that i feel
um that i'm a little bit more wary about
is because we do live in a day and age
where everyone
you know is almost like a walking brand
right through
social media or whatever it may be is
is is black pain
is that a fad and is it is it
is it something that it's um
you are speaking to your community by
showing
support because that is something that
is what you were supposed to do
and then what happens when um
another black man gets murdered and on
camera
and then another and then another and
then another
does your does your support fade away
because
the dominant community's no longer
talking about it um
does your support only stop because you
don't know what to do outside of just
posting something
um that's right yes the
so so to answer your question
there is there's a fundamental change in
terms of what the allies look like
um i think it's too soon to tell where
are we going
and as we talked about earlier today the
the i'm encouraged by especially the
younger voices
um amen and their actual
very active palpable participation yeah
um
i'm very much so discouraged by the
growing
blowback that's creating
even more of a divisiveness and in our
inability to have
a healthy nuanced conversation
from from different ideologies that
usually fundamentally kind of want the
same things you know
in terms of and oftentimes just don't
feel like they're getting
heard um so
so i i think the theme of la 92 is alive
and well
i think we're in a we're in a cycle
of um a very violent cycle which is also
just the history of this country
um and i think what happens next is i
think only time
time will tell that's not to say don't
bow out from
really trying to um
have empathetic conversations even with
those that disagree with you because
that's actually what needs to happen
yeah um we need to understand where the
vitriol
and the hate comes from um for those
that
let's be honest for i don't want to
stereotype it oftentimes
for people that what feels like they
don't even want
people that look like me or that are
darker than me to even be in their con
they're in the same community in the
same country
so and i think what i hear you saying is
like that
we need healing through conversation and
in order to have healing
there has to be a space where we can
speak our truths
and those truths have to be heard it's
not about you understanding or agreeing
with those truths it's just about we
need to be heard
and when you speak about where we are in
the industry and the landscape of
organizations and companies and black
lives matter i've never seen so many
people screaming black lives matter
that are not black right now and to your
point i'm like what does that mean and
that brings me to my
to my question is what is the role and
the responsibility of an ally
in your opinions what is what does that
look like and
and knowing that allies can show their
advocacy in different ways like you said
tj
they can show and post online right but
is that a fad is that when we're no
longer talking about hashtag
whoever um is that gone what what is
your
the ideas of the roles of allies don't
worry were you gonna say something
that's the fundamental question
what does alliance
truly look like and um
tj when you said is black pain
a fad
i think that is the
subject the phenomenon the the the thing
that people who want to be allies
have to answer for themselves
so that it is not a fad and that
brings me to a short passage that i
wanted to read i wanted
i want to share that i just read
recently
um you all uh
live in los angeles is that is that true
yeah yeah okay so i i
i only use the only reason i asked that
because i do not live in los angeles and
that doesn't make me better i just
just geographically it's connected to
what i'm about to read
so the question and i'm sorry if i sound
like a you know a college
lecturer right now but um
i want to ask um does everybody
on this call know who uh dijon kizzy is
is dejohn kizzy i hope i'm pronouncing
his name correctly
i didn't i i didn't know who he who he
was
either until i read this article
so let me just bear with me one second
in late august uh this is from the new
york the sunday new york times
uh september 13. okay
um in late august
los angeles sheriff's deputies shot a
black man
uh black man man's name is dijon
kizzy whom they had stopped for a
suspected
traffic violation as he rode his bicycle
he became the seventh man killed by
deputies in los angeles since the death
of george floyd in minneapolis
on memorial day weekend
on the same afternoon state
legislate state legislators in
sacramento
raced to the end of their 2020 session
the most significant police reform
measure
heralded in the days of the black lives
matter marches
that filled the streets did not
even come up for a vote
that to me and it's a longer article but
just those
opening paragraphs those opening two
paragraphs
are profoundly indicative of the
potential
fatism as you say tj
of black pain the fact that
none of us on this call myself included
knew who dijon kizzy
was is he stopped for a suspected
traffic violation
riding his bicycle so
um and the fact that the state
legislator
state legislature um
um clearly knew nothing about this
and it had no relationship to
whatever legislation was on the books
having to do with
potential police reform for me
that goes right to the heart of
the potential fatism
of black pain and how
when things are no longer um
top of mind for people
it very quickly reverts to business as
usual
um so to your question
excuse me to your question sean what
does alliance
look like i think that anybody
anybody on the planet not just in
america
but anybody on the planet who
views themselves or wants to view
themselves
as an ally of black people people
of color i think you have to ask
yourself the question
am i in it for the long haul
or am i in it um for the next month
or two or three because the
reality is um
as we know it's much longer than the
next month two months three months
next year two years three years
so i think um allies have to ask
themselves the question the very hard
question
um
am i down uh how long am i down for
to what extent am i willing to
negotiate my own humanity and my own
human
impulses and that's important
negotiating one's
own human impulses because
we as humans in it it is inherently
human that we go on to the next you know
we deal with whatever
but then we go on to the next that's
human
but i think for anybody who really wants
to be an ally you
i think the question then becomes to
what extent
how long am i in this for black people
don't have a choice because it's our
everyday reality
yes for anybody who wants to be an ally
i think they have to challenge
themselves with the question
how long am i down for how long am i in
this for what am i prepared to
to do
in the long term over the long haul
i'm sorry no just to cosign is also what
are you willing
to give up i mean there's this great
book that i read which was you know when
you're in the position of power
equity feels like oppression so when
you know folks start to feel that are
they going to
be in there for the long haul or are
they going to suddenly
realize oh i've got to give up something
and it's not worth it that's
where my fear lie that
that we i feel like we're getting to
that point um
and that article you just read is is
absolutely indicative of that
um yeah yep yeah
i don't know i i feel i think it's a
good question because i find myself
wrestling with it all all the time
and you know on a little bit more of an
existential
level it's it's a
that each individual has to be willing
to do a lot of hard
self analysis like there has to be a lot
of
hard truths that they have to face about
themselves in their relationship
to society and in
there's like the the
funny enough i mean it's it's nothing
new by any means but
for some reason uh you know gil scott
herron's
the revolution will not be televised has
been top of mind for me
lately because very much so as i wrestle
with my own involvement
in what my participation looks like
um not embedding not just embedding our
industry but
you know what's my pr my own activism
and participation
in the world look like but the reason
that has resonance
with me right is the crux of what he's
saying is
it won't be televised because everyone
has to have a revolution within which
you cannot capture
and i feel like the idea of that
needs to be is also at the center of
what allyship
looks like you have to keep pushing
yourself and challenging yourself
to understand and be willing and even
get to the place
of participating um in
in in a protest um where you're
participating with empathy and you're
participating by opening your ears
right that's leadership to me is
listening um
but that takes someone who's willing to
get over their own ego
right and that's that personal
revolution that has to happen
um and that's to me that's fundamental
otherwise that's also how we continue
this kind of
cycle and also like get fooled by just
like
bad you know nonsense news and nonsense
ideas of you know that equity is taking
something away from you like what the
[ __ ] is that
you know sorry i'm sure
we'll add something really quickly and
that is the um
um alliance and i i'm perhaps
stating the obvious and this is very
element elementary perhaps
but alliance as we know can take many
forms
and um for those of
us or those of you who are not
comfortable with marching in the streets
that's okay
i think that that's that's okay i think
that
the question when one starts to
um examine oneself and as you say tj i
mean you challenge oneself
um to define for oneself what that
alliance looks like
the potentially
beautiful thing quote unquote is that i
can take
many forms right
as long as one is doing
something on an ongoing basis
to enact change
um i i would say um
tj and and gina all of us
we may or may not be marching in the
streets um
but we are
engaging
i'm not going to say revolution i'm
going to say change agents
we are engaging we are we are um we are
manifesting the notion of becoming
change of of living
change agents through our work on
on on on one very fundamental level
each and every one of us um that's not
marching in the streets i mean
maybe some of us march maybe some of us
do not but i don't want to
and i'm sure you do not undervalue
underestimate the power you know of
cinema
of communication and that through our
work
our engaging our work we are impacting
frankly the world and i do not believe
that is hyperbole
um i believe it to be true
i think you're absolutely right though
delroy and i'm sure
i'm not sure but i got a lot of
questions around when the
whole unrest was happening and people
allies
or wanting to be allies asking how can i
participate what can i do
what can i learn what can i read what
can i watch and it's like
it's not my history you need to learn
it's yours
learn about my history i need you to
learn about your history i need you to
understand what
your part and not you specifically you
weren't around but your
your families probably need you to
understand because with that
understanding
of your own history comes what you spoke
about tj which is accountability
and then once you understand what that
is i need you to go educate
your other friends and then i need you
to amplify that
and that's the power that you have as an
ally you have the power to
have those spaces and have those
relationships that maybe we don't
necessarily have
but it is your job it is your job to not
learn my history it's your job to learn
yours and then it's your job to
not only educate everyone around you but
to amplify that message because then
that message is where
there is change and um i just wanted to
say to you all here thank you all
so much for your participation today and
to your point delroy
the entire reason for the academy
dialogues again was because they have
these conversations centered around
filmmaking centered around truth
centered around
race relations gender equality and um
you are all affecting the world and we
are all watching and we are all thankful
and grateful for your contribution
not only as humans but as filmmakers to
this
cinema black cinema universal cinema all
cinema because you guys do all
cinema also i want to thank you all so
much on behalf of the academy for
joining this conversation
on academy dialogues listen one
really really quick thing um at the
beginning of this
session you said you referred to
uh myself tj gina as
um uh i i'm paraphrasing that you you
spoke about the fact that we are all
at the forefront of something did you
say that it was something like that
you're
i said affecting i want to say it
probably said affecting culture
or yeah yeah something along those lines
and when you said that um i have to tell
you
that again internally my response was
okay i hope i'm affecting culture
whatever it was that you said
um what i'm aware of and no this is
important as it relates to
fatism i'm aware of
is that i am having a moment in my
career i
i'm not being coy i'm not trying to
underplay anything
i'm having a moment right now
specifically as it relates to
the fire bloods and i i'm proud of the
film i'm proud of the moment i'm
embracing the moment but my job
and probably for all of us
my job is a to acknowledge
that moment to embrace the specialness
of that moment and it's beautiful it's
been beautiful it's been extraordinary
but my job now is to
keep working
and not get caught up in whatever that
moment
has been may become
i want to embrace it but the larger
responsibility that i have
is to keep working keep
being so and i think for all of us
so that one does not get sucked into uh
fatism so that's all
yeah for all of us right 100 100
for all of us that's the i mean just
keeping keeping on is hard enough
right and it's the most
i mean for me it's the most important
thing
right is we won the oscar at a really
young age and
you start to you're listening to the way
with which other people are signing your
identity
and that's a really slippery slope um
to lose track of your own voice because
it was early in the development of even
discover i'm still kind of trying to
figure out what my voice is you know
and that's the part that's where the
the work is right i wanna that's right
on a career not a
amen a little like blip on that one
that's right amen amen myself
exactly right that's exactly right
um anyhow that was
i'm using all this so i
i love i love that because like you said
your voice and notice
knowing that your voice can change you
know what i mean and you can change and
want to
should be allowed to change yeah and
your voice should be allowed to change
you know as opposed to being in a box it
should yeah
your voice should be allowed to change
yeah and when you
and when you spoke about i heard you
speak a little bit about how your
hesitation towards
the role in the five bloods initially
because he was a trump supporter right
yeah and how you sat with that for a
little bit and understanding oh that
needs to be told too
and so use your voice to amplify
something that still needs to be told
and that story still needs to be told
because that's still clearly
the human experience you know and so
your voice can be allowed to change
you're we're all artists you know in any
in any sense of the word if you're
creating anything if you're living in
this world you are creating something
you're an artist
and it's your job involved to reinvent
to
create new space to figure out what the
pipeline is to mod you know to
create a space where you're mentoring
and bringing in new people but it's your
job to continue
finding yourself because that is your
job to then reflect it back to everybody
else
amen so true yeah y'all let's get off
because
clearly we will be talking forever god
bless y'all thank you it's uh been a
pleasure guys
thank you for watching academy dialogues
for more videos
please subscribe to our channel